hi I'm Ryan and tonight I'm going to be
watching the trailer reaction of Sally
low Monaco's reaction to transcendence
the second trailer for transcendence and
yeah i saw the transcendence trailer it
was awesome I know how this all looked
when I did it you know cuz it was it was
[ __ ] it was incredible it's
incredible trailer and ya salli what I
really like about Sally I really liked
watching trailers with her and I was
like yeah you should have your own trans
reaction [ __ ] and then she's like yeah I
could put it on your channel I was like
whoa [ __ ] slow the [ __ ] down you won't
put on my [ __ ] girl you better do
something to make me happy from gonna
get on my channel yeah she has her own
little trailer reaction playlist now you
know she's very sweet she's soft-spoken
but she's also very sincere and she
could be really goofy but she's always
kind of a surprise and she knows how to
play off people really well and yeah
she's awesome Jesus total cat she's hot
man I want to date her Sally I'm in love
with you I saw gal first trailer
reaction oh I'm so proud of my baby how
you doing my love she's gonna stop
posting trailers reaction yeah hey guys
my name is Sally this is going to be my
first solo trailer reaction I'm really
excited about this one and especially it
being my first because I'm a huge fan of
Johnny Depp lately he's been doing films
that don't necessarily seem like the old
Johnny Depp we used to know it just kind
of seems like the cartoony Johnny Depp
that became after Jack Sparrow and I'm
really excited I agree with that should
I grab that Sally and it just sounds
really cool so I'm going to react to the
trailer so you can react with me and
here we go okay
please welcome my partner in science and
in life dr. will caster the building
super intelligence requires us to unlock
the most fundamental secrets of the
universe universe there it is imagine a
machine with a full range of human hot
Sally or so pretty its analytical power
will be greater and the collective
intelligence of every person in the
history of the world some scientists
refer to this as the singularity
professor I call it transcendence a
series of attacks conducted by radical
anti-tech group known as rift they hit
absol over the country we lost decades
of research and development Morgan for
you really the balloon one hahaha the
effect is irreversible and she makes me
laugh but his mind is a pattern of
electrical signals we can upload his
consciousness we can save him
it is not assuming that this works if we
mistake a thought childhood memory how
will you know who you d he's not dead oh
my god I can't feel anything I'm here
you need to give me online I need more
power they may be intelligent may you
can be sent him this is a little mouth
shut it down this is my first time
watching like really shut down the
danger this is astounding it's bad with
my niece is weak acog and they I is like
any intelligent you're looking at two
people it has needs the real will die
it'll stop to evolve where's the machine
to controls
perhaps the entire world where are you
going
everywhere
I am so confused what transcended okay
I'm really confused I guess they did
that on purpose so that you'd watch the
movie but have some good actors in it
and can't go wrong with morgan freeman
like ever especially the lego movie that
was great so thank you guys for watching
go ahead and check out my channel at
salamander Sally I know I don't have
much up on that channel yet but I will
I'm planning to come out with a
Valentine's Day video which I'm filming
tomorrow also Justine a sub to this
channel cuz it's great and the boys are
great she mentioned me she said my name
specifically funny unless they make fun
of women's yeah I hope you enjoyed I
don't make fun of you tits I hope she
does not watch this video